[Music]
Joseph Stalin ran the sake union with as
is well known an iron grip but it wasn't
just his ruthlessness that was
remarkable it was the way in which he
structured governance so that it was
almost impossible for any two Soviet
citizens to have a private relationship
that was not in some sense known to and
subject to Stalin so he was the node
through which all other nodes had to go
to communicate and Stalin who was
famously paranoid was suspicious about
any interaction between Soviet citizens
and especially between a Soviet citizen
and a foreigner that he didn't know
about really interesting feature of
hierarchy that doesn't get understood I
think nearly well enough is that if you
are a hierarchical ruler you are right
to be paranoid and it's not just that
paranoid people tend to become dictators
it's more that if you're a dictator you
need to be paranoid because the real
threat to a hierarchy is a success for
the organized social network a social
network independent of the hierarch
of the big guy is the real threat once
saw that for example in Poland
why did Poland of all the communist
regimes get into trouble first because
there was a really well-organized civil
society or voluntary associations some
religious some not that formed a network
even before the Solidarity trade union
came along and that's lethal to a
hierarchical system which is why Stalin
was right if you want to put it this way
to be paranoid about social networking
that he didn't control didn't know about
it he understood that it doesn't take
too many additional edges in the network
to destroy the dominance of that central
node
so one way of thinking about this is
imagine a paramedic old structure
imagine something kind of like a
Christmas tree and there is the big guy
like the fairy on top of the Christmas
tree but imagine that on this Christmas
tree the lights are just connected to
the fairy they're not connected to one
another and therefore the fairy decides
if the lights go on or off it's it's a
peculiar kind of Christmas tree that
that's essentially a hierarchical
Network it wouldn't take too many
connections as it were lateral or
horizontal connections between the
lights to reduce the centrality of the
fairy on the tree and ultimately you
could end up illuminating the tree
without needing the fairy altogether so
I think that's why dictators hierarchs
need to be paranoid read the plays of
Shakespeare the suspicion that always
seems to haunt any of Shakespeare's
kings is that there is some kind of plot
some cabal some conspiracy going on and
and if you read the history of European
monarchy very often those suspicions
were well-founded what we call social
networks look like conspiracies to
absolute rulers and that's why very
often in history the terms seem to
overlap what looks like a social network
to you and me if we're in it looks like
a plot to the king if you want to see
the advantages of a hierarchical system
of government take a trip to China and
you'll see a system which is
extraordinarily high rock called Xi
Jinping is top man this system is good
at doing engineering projects if this
system decides on building high-speed
rail networks around China it can do it
with astonishing speed if the system
decides that it's going to build cities
in the expectation that there will be a
population to inhabit them it can do
that and so one of the most impressive
aspects of the last 30 years of human
history has been the spectacular growth
of the Chinese economy
and that has been in large measure of
the results of a highly effective
hierarchical system of planning of
course you would be naive if he went to
China's today and didn't see some of the
problems with doing that the problems of
pollution that have been a
characteristic feature of of modern
Chinese life there's also the problem of
corruption this is an everyday topic of
conversation in China a one-party
hierarchical system of government isn't
accountable it's above the law and
officials have routinely skimmed off
huge sums of money to line their own
pockets none of this comes as any news
to people who read Hayek's
great book the Road to Serfdom since the
mid 20th century classical liberal
scholars have said that the planned
economy is bound to be inefficient and
it's bound to lead to corruption and
other abuses of power I think most
people who think that way and I include
myself in that group were taken by
surprise by the success of China's
economic growth strategy can this system
endure through this 21st century that is
a huge question for China's leaders and
indeed for the world if you are like me
skeptical about that level of political
centralization your car is sitting
waiting for something to go wrong
because the defect of a hierarchical
system of government tends to be that
it's not responsive to signals from down
below that top-down governance tends to
be somewhat deaf not only does it not
necessarily get market signals it may
miss out on political dissidents
political discontent or to put it
differently you've created through rapid
industrialization at the biggest middle
class in all of history the biggest
bourgeoisie in history and if Karl Marx
were here sitting next to me
I think he'd agree
that that was very hard to reconcile
with the system devised by Mao Zedong to
centralize power in the hands of a
single party Marx would expect the
bourgeoisie in China to do what the
European bourgeoisie did in the 19th
century demand property rights and
therefore the rule of law to protect
property rights and therefore some
elements of representation in government
so even from a Marxist perspective
something has to change
so hierarchical systems of government
over time tend at some point to suffer a
loss of legitimacy a challenge from
below and we've seen that we saw the
mystery of the Soviet Union but we've
seen it elsewhere much less
sophisticated hierarchical systems like
the military regimes of Latin America or
the presidential regimes of the Middle
East came to grief in some cases well
before the Soviet Union did
[Music]